As Coca Cola and Pepsi exit Russia,...
...one local firm spies an opportunity.
Chernogolovka plans to fill the gap on store shelves.
Since May, it's been making its own cola...
...to replace products from the big names.
That market is worth around 9 billion dollars.
Now Chernogolovka is ramping up production to meet demand.
It's almost doubled output at one plant...
...and is working fast to build new facilities.
PepsiCo and Coca Cola suspended production in Russia in March.
Now Chernogolovka may also benefit from demand at fast food outlets.
It started supplying drinks through Russian outlets of Burger King and KFC.
Talks are also underway to supply Vkusno & Tochka.
That's what was McDonald's renamed...
...after the burger chain sold its Russian operations to a local firm.
Now, international sanctions mean some supply headaches for Chernogolovka.
But without Western rivals,...
...the firm says growth and maybe even a stock market listing,...
...are firmly on the agenda.